dijo que iba a convocar una
constituyente que iba a pasar el
proyecto entonces esto podría cambiar
ampliamente las normas del juego de aquí
en adelante
sí por supuesto podría por ejemplo
retirarse esa parte de la norma en donde
dice que el gobierno puede ser
destituido por incapacidad moral para
gobernar y se podría reglamentar cuáles
son específicamente los casos o podría
ser retirado entonces esta situación por
ejemplo no no le caería nada nada bien
al parlamento porque le quitaría el arma
o la lanza que suele utilizar frente al
ejecutivo
evidentemente hay algunos temas de la
norma constitucional que podrían ser
modificados o retirados y esto le
jugaría o le restaría poder al
parlamento a que el poder no
fiscalizador sino obstruccionista y de
enfrentamiento y que le da la capacidad
además de poder colocar a un nuevo
presidente de la república en caso de
que se termine
con el presidente y vicepresidente así
que en este caso incluso sobre una
vicepresidenta entonces esto podría
deben estar en mucho y obviamente hay
muchos intereses creados para que
tampoco se muevan las normas del juego
actual sin embargo la mayoría de
peruanos finalmente que puede ser
incluso por un voto hacer la mayoría ha
votado por un cambio en las reglas del
juego y habrá que hacer más evaluaciones
sociales pero las últimas que se
realizaron en evidencia del cambio de la
constitución en su mayoría la aprobaba
por que la consideraban injusta
socialmente y que obviamente con el
devenir de la pandemia había agudizado
aquellas diferencias